on a normal november day brian taut
would be preparing the bregier bar for
an evening's customers
but not this november no paying guests
will be coming through these doors for
the next four weeks
and brian is worried we saw more than 50
sales decline and the first lockdown um
you know throughout the summer as things
opened up a little bit we were able to
recover
somewhat um so having yet one more
lockdown right after an already tricky
summer where we had to operate with
restrictions in the first place
this uh and this is quite another
kick to the teeth that chimes with many
other service based industries who've
tried to make their businesses and
products
covet safe but must also now close down
but unlike in many other hard-hit
european countries
some essential shops and stores will
remain open
provided they maintain social distancing
schools remain open
in an effort to ease the financial pain
the government
is making more money available
our calculations show we need to make
use of up to 10
billion euros within one month you can
imagine that this will contribute to
softening the blow of the economic
consequences
and that this will enable us to help the
people that need it
underpinning the economic outlook is the
medical reality of this second wave
figures compiled here at the robert [ __ ]
institute show that almost a
fifth of all the infections in germany
so far have come in the last seven
days the number of patients being
treated in intensive care units has
doubled in a similar time
frame and the capacity of spare beds to
treat them
and the many more expected is rapidly
being eroded
meaning ministers felt they had to act
whether this massive combined effort
gets results in november will not be
because of the regulations per se
but whether they are followed as much of
life happens in the private sphere and
many people make highly personal
decisions about who they meet
we are highly dependent on participation
and the people in our country
accepting and following these rules
and that is part of an ethical argument
being made against the lockdown
some on the right and far right of
society say lockdown
infringes individual civil liberties
back at the boygire bar such thoughts
are distant
because for brian and many others in
similar industries
lockdown is a financial blow and the
government money on offer
cannot cover their losses completely
dominic kane
al jazeera berlin